PAUL LEWIS: Can I
just say up front
it is actually part of a
standardizing the platform
to make everybody [INAUDIBLE].
So it gives developers a
reliable and convenient way
to access developer
relations if we just say,
everybody's [INAUDIBLE].
So welcome to this session
on the applied science
of runtime performance--
and by runtime,
I mean rendering--
I basically mean
anything that isn't page load.
As Jake said, I am
one of the Pauls,
and I work on the
Developer Relations team.
And normally I focus on
both performance and design,
and when I normally
do my talks, I
do these fairly theoretical
kind of architecture-based talks
where I talk about pixel
pipelines and architectures
and how you get stuff
on screen and-- no.
This time I'm going to do
something completely different.
I'm going to do an
applied sciences talk.
I'm going to step you through
the process of building
something from my
point of view--
my own personal journey--
which is something
of an experiment for me because
I don't normally put this out
there.
And like all good
experiments, sometimes they
go a little bit wrong.
But hopefully it won't.
So we're stuck with it
now, so let's find out.
Hopefully, by now,
most of you have
seen this-- it's the
Chrome Dev Summit site.
I designed and built the thing.
And I set myself-- I can see
this talk is going to go well.
I won't be covering the
nitty-gritty details
of every aspect of
it, but I wanted
to step through the
thing that gave me
the most challenges and
the most interesting thing
that I could share with
you on that journey.
And it's this-- it has this hero
takeover effect with the cards.
There we go.
That's it on mobile.
And because we're responsive, of
course, this is it on desktop.
Same kind of deal.
Now what I want
to do first of all
is I want to step through
what we call the natural way.
So I think this is the
way that most of us
would think to
solve this problem.
We have a box that's moving on
screen-- it's getting bigger.
So probably we
think, right, let's
do this with CSS
because we've heard
that is good for performance.
So we'll transition
on width and height,
on left and on top-- that
seems like it'll do the job.
Unfortunately, it
gives us two problems,
and we'll step through
those very briefly.
Firstly, let me show you this.
This is a site I built a
while ago called CSS Triggers.
You can find it at
csstriggers.com.
And what you can do is you can
find any given CSS property
and it will tell
you what workload
it triggers in the browser.
So things like layout, paint,
and composite, for example.
And when we're building
fast-performing sites,
we want to trigger the least
amount of work possible.
Now unfortunately for us,
when we use left, top, width,
or height, we trigger
layout-- which
is the geometric calculations
of where everything
is on the screen-- we have the
paint filling in the pixels,
and then we have to composite
the [INAUDIBLE] together.
And basically when you've
got a reasonable-sized dom,
this is what the frames
per second looks like.
Now if you can't see,
let me zoom in for you.
This here is the 60
frames a second line,
which we're
obviously aiming for.
And you can see that when I
transition on width, height,
left, and top, that
essentially we're
pretty close to that 60
frames a second line.
And that's not good because
if we have garbage collection
or we have a freakishly long
paint for some reason, them
we're not going to
hit the frame target
and we're going to stutter.
So we're putting the browser
under strain every frame.
So if you don't normally
do the DevTools thing,
I highly recommend this.
Go into the DevTools,
go to Timeline,
hit Record, do whatever it is
that you do-- like scrolling
or whatever-- and
look at the bars
and just see how close you are.
Are you going over the
60 frames a second line?
Are you under?
How far under?
It's the first line
of defense to building
a really nice,
smooth experience.
So that's one thing.
We're pretty close
to that frame budget.
Here's the other problem.
Changing width and
height puts you
into pixel-rounded
kind of mode, which
means that even if you're
getting 60 frames a second,
because things are
moving per pixel,
they actually look like
they jitter a little bit.
That's what it actually
looks like to me.
And I don't like
that, personally.
I think it's jarring.
Actually looks like it jank
even though it's actually
doing pretty well.
By comparison, you get
some pixel rendering
when you change a transform,
and this turns out
to be quite useful
for animations.
So that's a thing
about the platform.
So I want to talk about
the unnatural way--
or I'm going to call it the
"other" way so I don't feel
so weird about it--
the way that I actually
end up building that effect.
So I'll step through the outline
of how I went about this.
So it starts with
this function here,
which is collecting
the properties.
So we're going to
expand the card, which
means we need to expand
what we know about the card.
So collectProperites--
it takes an object
on which we're going to store
all the things that we collect
about the card.
So what are we collecting?
Well, first of all we need
to what we're collecting on,
and we collect on things
like the title, the icon,
the content,
anything that's going
to animate in the
card we need to track.
And the collectProperites
looks like this.
You see here I
have the bit where
I ask for the
individual elements
that I'm interested
and tracking,
and then I ask for things like
the left and top and the width
and the height of
all those things,
which I get through this--
getBoundingClientRect, which
if you've never
used, is brilliant.
Because it gives
you an object that
looks like this with all
the correct numbers in.
And I have a disconcerting the
large amounts of love for this
function because it is
so unbelievably useful.
So big thanks to the IE
team because I believe that
was IE 4 that landed.
Well, I never.
Next week, on
"Esoteric Functions."
So once we've collected
all the information
about the card in its
collapsed position,
we now just expand
it out completely
to its final resting
place, like so.
Like this.
And we collect all
the positions again.
So now we know where you started
and we know where you finished.
And of course, we've
let the browser
do all the work in the middle.
I don't say how wide or high--
I just asked the question, how
wide and high, and I collect it.
So it's in this final position.
And now I calculate
where everything moved.
And then I apply a
transform to reverse it.
So it looks like this.
No, this all happens
very quickly.
You might not have seen
this effect on the site
because it doesn't
happen like this.
And you might look at this and
you go, OK, it looks roughly
in the right place,
Paul, but there
appears to be quite
a lot of pink.
That's right.
But if we clip it, shazam.
There we go.
It's like it never
happened, right?
The good thing about
this particular approach
is now we're ready to rumble.
Because all we've got are
transformed and opacity changes
that we've applied,
and that means
we're nice and
composite-friendly.
If you look at csstriggers.com
and you type in "transform,"
it'll go, compositor.
That's it.
And compositor stuff
typically is very fast today.
So we switch on
animations and we
just clear out all
those transforms.
Like this.
Look here.
This is the function
that does it.
Translate to nothing,
scale to one.
And go to your final opacity.
And it gives us--
we also animate
the clip around the
whole thing, by the way--
should mention that.
And it gives us the effect that
we've come to know and love.
And I think a good
question at this point
is, why are you
doing it this way?
It's way more work.
Right.
Way more work.
And you're right--
it is more work.
And my hope is that
the natural animations
way will become faster.
And as you heard
this morning, we're
investing a lot
of time and effort
into making that a reality.
But this is my journey
through building this,
and this is just the state
of things as they are.
Anyway, it is more work and to
kind of summarize my feeling,
actually, there's a
quote from John Gruber
recently that I thought was
excellent in this regard.
He said, "The point of making
apps shouldn't be about making
life easier for developers"--
in this case, me--
"it's about making the best
possible apps for users"--
in this case, you.
So, yes, it is
definitely harder.
But you can encapsulate
this into a web component
and then never worry
about it again and give it
to other people, and they never
need to worry about it again--
which is kind of what
[INAUDIBLE] does,
and it's pretty cool.
And I generally think that
performance matters, right?
Matters to users, as
we heard this morning
with the takeover--
the hero effect.
Users really feel it.
They may not be able
to say what it is,
but they feel and
it matters and they
want something that
feels great to use.
So I think it's
worth the investment.
Anyways, this was is actually
faster than the other way.
Let's look at the
timeline again.
And you see now we're way
lower-- in the middle.
I say "in the middle" because
the eagle-eyed amongst
us will be saying,
surely, Paul, this is bad.
And that's a fair
question, I think.
And so to answer that,
I want to introduce you
to what I call the
Picasso principal, which
in this-- "Learn the rules
like a pro so that you
can break them like an artist."
It works for anything.
Write it down.
You go back to your office--
"I'm like an artist.
I'm an artist."
It works very well.
You can say, Archimedes said
"Use will change sparingly,"--
he didn't.
But Picasso did say this and,
yes, learn the rules like a pro
so you can break
them like an artist.
Which is not to
say I'm an artist,
although I am pretty
handy with crayons.
It's true, it's true.
I actually drew this and my son
looked at it and went, Daddy,
what is it?
It's a picture.
It's better than yours.
Didn't say that.
All right.
So these rules that we're
going to break-- they're
not my rules.
I don't really go in for rules.
But they are things
that you hear
when you're learning
web development.
And they come from a good place.
They come from noble intentions,
but I think we can break some.
Let me show you what I mean.
Rule number one--
no frame should ever
exceed 16 milliseconds.
It's actually pretty
good because we
want 60 frames a second.
One second divided by 60
gives us 16 milliseconds.
But it's actually not
the whole picture.
What I mean by that is
this-- when the user taps
or clicks on something, we
actually have 100 milliseconds
in which to respond before the
user goes, that didn't respond,
did it?
So we've got 100 milliseconds
that we bought, time-wise.
The animation starts.
The animation runs and ends.
And then we have a little
period at the end where
we pick up the pieces and go,
OK, before the user actually
notices that the
animation's ended,
we've got this
little window here.
It's only this bit
in the middle that
needs to be 60 frames a second.
So if we bring back
that timeline snapshot,
you'll see that it follows
that pattern very closely.
The beginning where we
do all the measurement
stuff or the toggling of
classes and so on-- that's
that bar on the left, and it's
roughly about 71 milliseconds
on a Nexus 5.
I memorized the number.
It's not like I'm
looking at the bar
and I've got some
freakish talent
where I can tell you how
long a frame was just
by looking at the bar.
And then at the end is
about 43-ish milliseconds.
So we're inside that
window-- that model
of where you can say--
actually, before I kick off
an animation, if I have
expensive work to do,
I should do it now so
I could run cheaply
through the middle
of the animation.
Rather than going
on every frame,
I should do expensive things.
Because then you're much
more likely to hit problems.
So then, rule number
one-- no frame
should exceed 16 milliseconds.
No chance.
Of course, there are times-- you
want to be 60 frames a second
all the time.
Of course you do.
Why wouldn't you?
But there are times
where it matters
more than others, and
during an animation
is where it really matters
to the user's experience
and that's the thing
to concentrate on.
You do have these little
windows of opportunity
during kind of idle
time and so forth
where you might be
able to do expensive
work and save
yourself some hustle.
By the way, when
I say animations,
here as well scrolling should
be considered an animation.
Things are moving on screen.
So don't, in that sense, treat
scrolling as a separate thing.
It should scroll at
60 frames a second.
So you might be wondering
then, weren't there
any other rules that you decided
to break during this build,
Paul?
Yes, yes, yes, indeed.
There you are.
Because I named that one rule
number one, so it follows
there may be other rules.
Rule number two-- never trigger
a forced synchronous layout
or layout thrashing-- you may
have heard it called that.
Who would do such a thing?
Let me show you the card
expansion code again.
So to recap, collected in
its collapsed position,
expanded and collect again,
calculate what we move to
and reset it, switch on
animations and go out again.
The problem is in this
section here, and particularly
these two functions.
Because they set the
transforms and opacities.
Now, because of the
way browsers optimize,
it defers those to
the end of the frame.
And unfortunately,
the second one
now stomps over the
top of the first one.
And it's kind of like the
first one never happened.
So we've set our card
to its expanded state.
We then applied a
transform that did nothing.
And the net effect is no
animations whatsoever.
Boo-hoo, boo-hoo.
What we need to do is we need
to force the browser to realise
that we set some styles before
we start changing them again.
And this is where the
forced layout would help us.
To do that, we can add
something like this, which
asks for something like a width,
a height, a padding, a margin,
the bounding client
rectangle, anything from CSS
triggers that tell you it
triggers layouts would probably
be enough to get this.
So never, ever, ever
force a sync layout.
Never trigger one of those.
You can call me Pablo.
It works because I'm
Paul, not because I'm
an artist-- although
clearly I am.
There are subtleties here
that I do need to call out.
Firstly, I'm only doing this in
that long-running first frame.
The 100 milliseconds that
I have as a window-- that's
my opportunity to
do this kind of work
as dangerous and
expensive is it might be,
that's the time to do it.
The other thing is I'm
not doing it repeatedly,
which would be very bad because
if I went read, write, read,
write, read, write--
that's causing
Chrome to do an awful lot.
It's causing every browser
do an awful lot of things
that you don't want it to do.
So caveat's out of the way.
So it's all plain
sailing, right?
No.
Let's hit Pause a second.
There is a slight problem.
And I want to show
you-- again, this
is all about my own kind
of-- it's quite cathartic.
This is like therapy.
Not everything is jank-free.
Things are miles
better than they were,
but there are times where
every browser at some point, it
does jank.
Let me show you what I mean.
This is occasionally in Chrome.
You may have seen
it stutter there.
I'll do it slow-mo
and just bar in
mind the jank looks even
worse in slow motion.
Every time.
I feel like it is my fault.
I should say that.
It's also bad in other browsers.
Let me show you
in mobile Safari.
Does that as well occasionally.
So same kind of deal.
Let me show you why that is.
It's because of
this line here when
I said I animated the clip
that was around the box.
"Clip" triggers paint.
Again, if we look
back at CSS triggers
and we look at that,
that's its profile
there-- it doesn't
trigger layout
but it does trigger paints and
it does trigger compositing.
So on non-Chrome browsers,
it always causes jank.
It always causes problems.
And on Chrome desktop,
it's typically
fast enough to not be a problem.
On Chrome and Android,
it's only occasional.
And it's better when there's
GPU rasterization switched on,
in which case it is
significantly better.
So that's really nice.
But to be completely
honest, I was
on the fence about
the whole effect
because-- maybe I
should just kill it.
Maybe I should
just scale it back.
And that's where it brings me
to rule number three, which
is "never sniff the
user agent string."
Don't judge me.
We're all friends, right?
The card JavaScript file--
I have this flag in it,
and it says run
lo-fi animations when
you can't cope with
fast clip animations.
Which is effectively
a wrap-around way
of saying today, is it Chrome?
I've named the
function like this
because my intention is
to keep this up to date
and my hope is that every
browser will get better
at dealing with clip animations.
But right now, this is
the state of things.
I just don't think
clipping is something
that people have really
tried to do a lot of,
whether it's overflow
[INAUDIBLE] like animating
these things.
But as these effects start
to open up to us-- which
they are doing--
then we're going
to try more and more
of these things.
And that's a really
interesting place for us to be.
So this is what it looks
like on desktop Safari.
It's the same on
mobile Safari as well.
You see that?
There we go.
And it's no bad thing, actually.
It runs well.
It does the effect nicely.
And I think this for me was
the important distinction when
I was sort of reasoning
this out to myself--
is that I don't use it to
redirect you to an [? m dot ?]
site or to say, no, you
can't have the thing.
What I'm trying to do is trying
to just give you something,
but because I'm confident that
you can't have the fast clip
animations, I just don't
want to ruin your experience.
So for me, that's kind of
how I've thought about this.
So I think in very
specific circumstances,
you might feel OK
about UA sniffing.
But then I would say that,
given that's what I did, right?
So you may disagree, and I'm
100% cool with that, I think.
The question, though,
for me may be,
why even leave it in if it's
not perfect everywhere, Paul?
What were you thinking?
And I want to explain why I did.
Firstly, I think it's
important to push boundaries.
It's partly my job,
but it's also partly
what I think we need
to do as an industry.
We need to find out
where the boundaries are.
We need to say, this is the
kind of thing I want to make,
[GRUNTING] and push.
I think that's a good idea.
I think the web deserves
those great user experiences.
I think it can act as
something of a signpost,
as well, like, these
are the kind of things
you can do on the web.
Secondly, it does hit
60 frames a second.
I'm quite tough on myself.
I'm a bit of a perfectionist.
On desktop, it runs very well.
On mobile, it typically
runs well as well.
It's just occasionally.
I believe it will get
significantly better--
not only through GPU
rasterization in Chrome,
but I think every
browser vendor has
got very smart people working
on these kinds of problems.
And lastly but not leastly, I
like giving Chrome engineers
headaches.
Why is this slow?
I'm kidding, of
course-- or am I?
One thing I want to say about
all those rules or any received
wisdom is if you decide to go
against it for whatever reason,
you're responsible for it.
In the same way, I'm now
responsible for the Chrome Dev
Summit site.
And if browsers fix
their performance issues
in this area, I will have to
keep that function up to date.
That's my responsibility
and I believe
that's the
responsibility we have.
It's important that we make
sure that our stuff does
the most that it can, and
we don't just sort of launch
and forget.
So I think that's something that
I really wanted to call out.
So I'll be keeping
that code up to date.
Because it's not
future-facing, so I
have to drag it into
the future with me.
So guided tour
through building this.
Just that.
There you go.
Great.
So I wanted to cover off a few
of the bits and pieces sort
of related to the
site, but also sort
of related to the whole
runtime rendering stuff
that I think is helpful.
Let's talk about debugging
animations for a second.
It's hard, isn't it?
Good news-- this is
pretty fast, right?
If it runs.
Going to run?
OK.
Pretty fast.
There's a good
experimental feature
that we're on the process
of making here in DevTools.
And I can go in and I can
switch down the global playback
speed here of the animations.
And-- wait.
Going to pause it now
because I want to do that.
I just want to pause it.
Just wait there.
Hold on.
And then I can
inspect the element
itself, which I
think is this one.
And it tells me
all the animations
that occur on that
and its children.
And as I roll over
each one of those,
it's going to show me which
element it's referring to.
I can dive into one.
I can scrub it back and forth.
And I can also inspect the
actual properties at that point
and say, what
values do you have?
Now, this is not ready just yet.
It's experimental.
We wanted to give you a bit of
a sneak peak-- show you what's
coming down the wire.
We know that debugging
animations is hard
and we're doing a lot of
work to make it far easier.
So that's going to
be a lot of fun.
Next thing-- I actually
mentioned this earlier,
but I do want to call it out.
The site will run
when you're offline.
Now at this conference,
the Wi-Fi is really good.
At not every
conference have I been
to that I could
say the same thing.
And so for me, a conference
site that works offline
is actually really quite useful.
And of course, it is
because of Service Worker.
Alex did a great
job of talking you
through all that stuff earlier.
But I did want to add my own
little bit that I am using it.
It's kind of a-- let's call it
[INAUDIBLE] cache replacement.
It's about resilience
for bad Wi-Fi
and fast bootstrapping
of the site,
rather than anything
more adventures.
It's really quite
simple on the inside.
On a fetch, I
basically say, do you
have something in the cache?
If yes, return it.
If no, go and fetch it.
And then when you've got
your answer back, assuming we
can cache it, cache
it and then return it.
It's pretty simple
and I kind of like it.
Another reason I really
like Service Worker,
personally speaking, is this.
I think historically,
we've been in a situation
where we've been
very network-bound.
It's like having to
install an app every time
you want to use the app, right?
And I don't know
about you, but when
I have a native app open that
does pretty similar things
and I'm trying to
decide which app I want,
I don't go, you know what, this
was 3.2 megabytes from the Play
Store, this was 4--
I can't deal with it.
I basically say, look, this
has a better user experience,
it's got a better design,
it's got a better feel to it,
I like this one more
than I like this one.
I think that's an
important distinction.
Service Worker has the
potential to give us
these fast bootstrapping,
fast launching experiences.
Now, I should say that
it doesn't do away
with the network concerns we've
had so far because you've still
got that first load where
you need to get your Service
Worker in place.
But the future-- this sort
of second time onwards-- then
it starts to get a lot better.
And I think for me,
that shift is saying--
like when two things, two
sites, or two web apps
do similar things, the
differentiator becomes
the runtime.
How well does this
thing perform?
How well is it designed?
And was is user experience like?
I think that's pretty cool.
Other thing that people have
mentioned to me in the past
is that it's very difficult
to figure out in the wild
how you're doing from a
frame-specific point of view.
So it's OK.
You've got DevTools Timeline and
that's great for your machine
and maybe you get a little
bit of stuff going on
in your device lab if
you've got one-- great.
But what can I do when I've got
thousands, tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands of
users out in the wild?
Well, this is where the
frame-timing API could help us.
Now, just to warn
you, it's in sort
of spec state at the moment.
It's being discussed by the w3c.
So bear that in mind.
This is the w3c repo,
which has this address--
w3c frame-timing.
It doesn't explain a doc there.
There is the latest
draft of this spec.
So you go and dive into that and
figure out a little bit more.
But I want to give you
the kind of elevator pitch
for what you get
with it as it stands.
So there are all these
render or main thread events.
So main thread is
where your JavaScript
runs, where style calculations
are done, where layout is done.
And you can ask
for these records.
And each one comes back,
looks a little bit like this.
There's a unique number for
each frame, it has a startTime,
and it has a cpuTime.
Now, you could use this
to kind of step up.
Say you're got an
array of these.
Does the start time go open 16
or so millisecond intervals?
If so, I have
something that runs
on the main thread at
about 60 frames a second.
But more than that
with the cpuTime,
I can figure out how comfortably
or not I was doing this.
If I have a cpuTime of
near 60 milliseconds,
I'm really close to
that boundary, aren't I?
And there's not a lot
that might push me over.
Whereas if I've got low cpuTime,
then I'm making it with ease.
And with lower
cpuTime, of course,
hopefully becomes low battery
drain as well as a bonus.
So you get a lot of information
just from these three things.
But you can also ask for
compositor events from this,
as well.
So with the compositor
thread on Chrome and Android,
that's where the painting
and rasterization-- well, it
depends whether
the GP raster's on.
That's where painting
happens and it's
where compositing happens.
And the events for
that look like these.
Again, they've got the
same frame number system
and given the way
composing works,
sometimes there are
multiple composites
per main or render thread event.
And so you can tie them
back with this number.
How many-- I've got a bunch of
these for 120-- tie them back.
We also have the
startTIme as well.
There is some
discussion, I believe,
as to whether there should
be cpuTime here as well.
So if you feel
strongly either way,
that's where the
Git Hub repo is for.
That's where the issues are for.
Go and make your voice be heard.
So it would take a while for
me to explain exactly what you
could do with all this,
but here's some ideas.
You could track the
frames per second all
of your JavaScript and
your CSS animations.
You could figure out, hey,
when a video's playing,
the side navbar
doesn't run very well.
You could track your
scrolling performance.
It scrolls fine on our machines
here, but for whatever reason
on these devices over here,
it doesn't scroll well.
You could beacon out
data back to Analytics.
So on Aggregate, you
could start figuring out
that people in a particular
part of the world
are using a device that
you don't have in your lab.
Now would be a good
time to go and buy
that and fix the
issues that they have.
And you can start doing
this much more broadly.
And then lastly,
you can automate
and you could alert
on regressions.
The new person joins the
team, they're well-meaning,
they add will-change to
everything, everything
collapses And you
go, what happened?
Hopefully you can catch that
early before you deploy--
get in.
So FrameTime API-- I think
that's really exciting.
I'm really looking forward.
I hope this ships.
I just want to give you
the heads-up that it's
something that's
being discussed.
Coming back to the site,
there is one other thing
I wanted to mention--
it's open source.
You can learn from my
mistakes, my successes,
and I would love
for you to do that.
The code is as neat and
tidy as I can muster.
It's not bad.
Please do take a look.
It is on GitHub, Google
Chrome, Dev Summit.
There was another commit
I did this morning-- fixed
a bit of an issue.
I'm keeping an eye on it.
There are interesting things.
Many things I would look at
personally-- the card.js file,
and the Service Worker--
two really interesting bits.
But there are interesting
things in there
about how I manage URLs,
so I'll leave that one
as a bit of a tempter.
Go and have a look.
It's really cool.
So to finish up, I
guess my journey--
the conclusions I
drew from it were
that you should push boundaries.
Like I said, the web I believe
deserves these fantastic user
experiences.
It deserves-- I was pushing
really hard on this.
Good performance, though,
isn't always easy.
And we are doing a lot to
try and make it easier--
to try make that
natural animations way
just the way that you do
things so that you don't have
to keep in your head all these
different ways of doing things.
It isn't easy, but it is
absolutely always worth it.
I take from the clap
that you gave me,
which I really appreciate,
that you like the site.
And so for me, I
can now tell you
for definite-- it was worth it.
Because as I would
always say, performance
matters, as you've shown me.
Thank you.